Liu rejects heloo rejects my name is
Jenny do wait all the rum go well I just
got back from the gym and I briefly
checked the comments but all of them
were about how pirates of the caribbean
dead men tell no tales the trailer is
out more swash buckling angry drunk
inspirational pirate for us from the
johnny depp role that catapulted him and
also launched a [ __ ] ton of other
caricatures man he used to be something
special something i mean thing is he's
still pretty good like mass was alright
[Music]
Brook I feel like I don't see his
production company as often good
vegetables
[Music]
Oh
for the first movie no it's not
that Orlando Bloom
or DB or hobby unannounced bathroom do
you go by it only by name Sparra for me
I'm really a message
[Music]
please
all right okay
interesting interesting I mean it's not
a whole lot you can review here from
this one specific teaser trailer in
terms of its look and style it's all
gone some positives here okay that in
terms of his looking style looks cool I
mean it looks like all the other Pirates
of the Caribbean movies I thought at
first like all that stuff on this ship
was just taking footage from the first
movie for some reason it looked like
that when barbosa's men were you know
they're all ghosts or whatever they were
skeleton things
I mean Javier Bardem as a villain we all
know Hardware Brad dam is a wonderful
actor and we all know that Javier Bardem
can play villainous roles I'd be more
excited honestly if it wasn't Javier
Bardem because I'm like I've seen Javier
Bardem play a bad guy several times now
very memorable villains maybe he could
bring something very fresh to this I
mean currently just from watching that
teaser even though it doesn't show much
it's still kind of made me go this looks
like every other Pirates of the
Caribbean movie of a deadly villainous
pirate
that's hates Jack Sparrow and wants Jack
Sparrow dead cuz Jack Sparrow did
something to piss him off that was black
beard that was Barbeau so that was Davey
Jones and it's like okay similar set up
of the villain look of it it's cool to
see the Pirates of the Caribbean world
because I'm always drawn to them here's
here's my feelings about the films the
first one is a magical experience I
still think the first one is fantastic
to this day I consider one of the best
movie theatre experiences of my entire
life the second one I didn't like it the
first time I saw it the second time I
watched into the theaters I loved it
that is one of those rare films that a
lot of people might insult and say it's
[ __ ] but I personally think it's a
really good film the third one I can't
stand the fourth one is so bad I kind of
liked the last hour of the fourth one
but everything leading up to that last
hour was just a night experience I know
they got some of the same riders back
for this one they got like these two
directors these co directors I know the
other
ones were directed by just you know one
director this one they got the guys who
directed a couple episodes of Marco Polo
and I'm sure they can capture like a
cool visual style and maybe a sense for
the historical moment in which this
takes place but a really dark teaser
trailer kind of didn't really care for
that I want these movies to be really
fun you know it's something that I feel
is kind of a start getting really
serious around at worlds and it's just
like go back to making this a magical
fun experience I mean you don't even see
Jack Sparrow in its trailer like that
some of the few reasons we still stick
around hoping Jack Sparrow will be great
again even though I feel like in the
last one he really like phoned it in
Johnny Depp I'm hoping this time he goes
back to now at least trying to embody
the role or really make it something
more organic and real and I know Orlando
Bloom is supposed to return that I'm
really interested to see cuz I missed
him in the fourth one I'm not like the
biggest role and abloom fan but I do
like him in the Pirates of the Caribbean
films so forth for a teaser trailer I
felt like this could have been a little
better I was honestly a little excited
to watch this because I was like alright
it's been a few years they probably like
took time to think okay what can we do
different people were not so happy I
know the last one made over a billion
dollars but I'm sure they heard that a
lot of people were not so happy with it
so far don't really have much to go off
of that makes me go this looks like it's
gonna be worthwhile time Javier Bardem
like I said I know he's a great actor
he's probably gonna do a really good job
he's probably gonna fit the shoes of
this role well nothing about his his
pirate character strikes me as different
from what I've seen Ian McShane do what
I've seen Geoffrey Rush do to me Bill
Nighy as Davy Jones was a fantastic
villain I didn't feel like Blackbeard
was that good of a villain in here I
feel like we're kind of trying to do a
cross of like having it somewhat be a
human character but he's clearly not a
human I'm definitely gonna give this
movie a shot no even if I see another
trailer the trailer is a feeling more
like [ __ ] to me I'm still gonna watch
this movie so Disney you have my money
already just know I'm probably gonna be
there opening night
I just really hope the next trailer
reveal to us shows us that there's going
to be some things brought back that we
missed and there's going to be new
things to explore here too because right
now is right now super mystical pirate
villain
hating Jack Sparrow been like yeah
that's like every [ __ ] pirates movie
and I'd like to see Jack Sparrow in the
trailer too and I like to Sierra Lando
bloom because right now all those things
you guys have released of this movie
sounds cool
you know how we're barred am in the
movie bringing Orlando Bloom back
getting different directors in there I
like the subtitle of dead men tell no
tales well right now this teaser hasn't
really shown me enough to make me go
yeah this is gonna be cool I hope you
guys are upset at me for not literally
liking it sorry this is my honest
opinion I just don't feel like the last
couple movies have been good enough for
me to just be excited to be back in this
world but still yo I money and that's
what matters to these movie studios
anyway alright rejects it if you're not
a reject subscribe and become a reject
meaning you won't be a reject as you're
part of a community of other rejects
hence you you know what I'm going here
make sure to like our real rejects
Facebook page follow us on Twitter and
Instagram and I want to give a shout out
to the first subscriber who I saw
comment about this trailer coming out
mr. troll fish fish mr. troll fish fish
you know I think of I think of like Nia
fish sometimes a symbolism for Jesus but
you're finding yourself mr. troll
so you're the devil Satan watches this
channel I'm Limburger